Normalerweise, lieber Jens, gibt's da Zitate, die man hört über dieses Intro. Aber ich hab's nicht mehr geschafft, diese ganzen Aufsager, die du bei Sportradio360 hast, rauszuklippen. Das nächste Mal musst du mir welche schicken.
Mach ich gerne vorab.
Schön, dass du hier bist.
Ich freu mich jedes Jahr. Ich bin zum dritten Mal, glaube ich, hier bei dir, Max. Der Tee ist besser denn je. Was soll ich denn sagen? Das Wetter ist beschissener denn je draußen. Aber großartigerweise, die SVM in München, es funktioniert einfach alles. Ich bin gerne in München, selbst bei diesem Wetter.
Die SVM, du meinst die MVG? Genau, die meine ich.
Die meine ich, man verkehrsbetrieb es. SVM ist irgendwas anderes. Was weiß ich.
Irgendwas anderes. Also Jens Huiber ist hier. Der Producer von Sportradio360. Jens, ich bin ein großer Fan. Ich freue mich immer. Ich freue mich wirklich jedes Jahr, wenn du hier bist.
Nein, ich freue mich auch, dich zu sehen.
Und ich wusste, dass du das relativierst. Deswegen habe ich, ich habe was für dich. Also es gibt doch, du kennst doch Spotify-Rap. Wird man ja gerade zugemüllt mit. Übrigens, kurzer Hinweis darauf. Also wir freuen uns natürlich, wenn ihr unsere Formate hört. Ich spreche jetzt einfach erstmal für mich. Und dann sagst du, ob du zustimmst. Aber Spotify, hört uns doch bitte in einem anderen Podcast-Player. Spotify bringt uns am allerwenigsten. Ich weiß nicht, ob du irgendwie stattfindest bei Spotify. So in irgendwelchen Charts?
Nein, in den Charts überhaupt nicht. Aber ich hab halt auch einen Ableger. Also man kann uns bei Spotify hören, bei Open Spotify. Aber ich würde es auch präferieren, wenn ihr uns abonniert. In irgendeiner Art und Weise. Oder direkt von der Seite hört, wo die Einzelteile der Show, der Big Show auch zu hören sind.
Genau. Oder eben in anderen Podcast-Playern. Ich nutze sehr gern Pocketcast. Weil der Grund dafür ist einfach, Spotify verdient mit uns beiden nichts. Wir machen zu lange Sendungen. Und deswegen hat Spotify keinerlei, wirklich keinerlei Interesse, dass wir Erfolg haben. Dementsprechend finden wir auf Spotify nicht statt. Es wundert mich fast, dass so viele von euch uns noch über Spotify hören. In den Statistiken sehen, es sind so pro Sendung irgendwie so 4.000, 5.000, bei irgendwie 30.000 insgesamt. Die meisten kommen dann noch über andere Plattformen.
Das ist bei dir, Max. Diese Zahlen sind bei dir, nicht bei mir.
Ja, aber deswegen, bei Spotify hat der Rasenfunk keine Zukunft. Also Spotify wird nichts dafür tun, dass der Rasenfunk da auch nur irgendwelche HörerInnen findet. Deswegen tendenziell sind andere Plattformen für uns vorteilhafter. So, und was ich aber jetzt zeigen wollte, es gibt ja Spotify-Rap und das gibt es auch bei Pocketcast. Pocketcast, dein Jahr im Podcast. So, jetzt lädt das hier kurz. Ich mach das live, damit man sieht, es ist auch nicht gefaked. Mein Jahr, ich hab 74 verschiedene Shows und 868 Folgen angehört. Sportradio360 war deine am häufigsten angehörte Show im Jahr 2023. 47 Folgen mit einer Gesamtdauer von sechs Tagen und neun Stunden.
Du siehst mich beschämt.
Ja, du siehst mich beschämt, dass ich nicht alle 52 Big Shows gehört hab. Die gibt es auch nicht. Ja, wahrscheinlich sind es deswegen. Also ich müsste alle in diesem Jahr gehört haben. Es würde mich wundern, wenn nicht.
Ich meine ja, es kommen noch ein paar. Und vielleicht hab ich mal eine Woche Pause gemacht. Vielleicht ganz zu Beginn des Jahres.
Also deswegen, ich wollte damit nur sagen, ich höre das Sportradio360, jede Big Show. Und ich glaube, weil ich auch weiß, dass über YouTube da draußen, bist du aufgeregt, dass wir auch auf YouTube sehen. Da gibt es wahrscheinlich viele, die das Sportradio noch nicht kennen. Deswegen sag doch nochmal, was machst du da?
Big Show ist, da ist der Name ein bisschen Programm. Wir versuchen uns eben, also Max, du hast eine super Expertise im Fußball. Die maßen wir uns gar nicht an, aber ich habe großes Interesse an allen Sportarten. An vielen Sportarten, mit denen ich groß geworden bin, bin ich dann doch deutlich älter als du. In Elton hast du aufgewachsen, wo wirklich den ganzen Tag Olympische Spiele gelaufen sind. Tennis, Formel 1 als Österreicher, wenn man es denn noch hört, als Österreicher Formel 1 ist fast...
Du kannst das Abfahrtsergebnis von 1982 aus dem Kopf rezitieren.
Und die Zwischenzeiten dazu, das muss man auch sagen. Werner Grissmann, immer Zwischenzeitweltmeister. Ich habe immer noch dadurch geprägt von meinen Eltern, von meinem Vater vor allen Dingen, immer noch ein wahnsinniges Interesse an Sport. Eben nicht nur an Fußball, Fußball auch, aber eben auch an anderen Sportarten. Bei Sportradio360 machen wir seit 2011, machen wir jeden Donnerstag die Big Show, sportradio360.de und versuchen eben zumindest die Themen, wo ich ein gesteigertes Interesse habe und wo ich auch in der Lage bin, Experten zu finden. Darum geht es ja immer, die mir dann erklären, was ich gerne wissen möchte oder meine vorgefasste Meinung bestätigen. Wo wir über alles sprechen. Und auch in dieser Show, in der aktuellen Big Show 638 beginnt es mit Fußball. Und dann kommt aber eben einer meiner lieben Freunde mittlerweile, obwohl ich mich privat nie mit ihm treffe, Michael Körner zum Beispiel, wo wir über Napoleon sprechen.
Das war überhaupt das beste Sequent überhaupt. Ich habe es geliebt, habe schon am Kochen gehört gestern.
Wir müssen, also mit Michael Körner kann man über das Leben sprechen. Aber dann gibt es eben auch Motorsport, es gibt die NBA, es gibt natürlich generell American Sports, also National Football League. Es geht immer etwas über Tennis dabei, jetzt im Winter. Alpiner Skisport, Motorsport. Also all das, wo ich denke, dass ich persönlichen Interesse habe, natürlich sind da Sportarten dabei, die fehlen, weil mir da der Zugang fehlt. Also gerne würde ich sehr viel mehr über das Turnen machen, Männer und Frauen, aber ich habe einfach keine Ahnung. Und ich habe auch niemand, der mir das erklären kann. Und ehrlicherweise sind natürlich jetzt auch nicht so viele Turnwettbewerbe, wo man sagt, die müssen jetzt unbedingt gecovert werden. Aber wenn Weltmeisterschaften sind, oder letztes Jahr im Sommer, vor allem diese European Games in München, da hatte ich dann Volker Kreisler von der Süddeutschen Zeitung, der sich sehr gut auskennt. Und da gab es ja auch deutsche Erfolge bei Frauen und Männern. Da nehme ich auch das mit rein. Aber eigentlich unsere Idee, meine Idee ist, dass wir so viele Sportarten wie möglich feiern, auch beleuchten und gern auch mal kritisch beleuchten. Aber es läuft dann doch immer darauf raus, dass wir halt den Sport lieben und deshalb alles mitnehmen.
Dass man alles mitnimmt. Und dann gibt es eben irgendwie so einen festen Pool an Gästen, den man hat. Das kenne ich ja auch selber auch. Du hast ja noch mal viel mehr Leute zu organisieren. Du hast quasi jede Woche so einen kleinen Rasenfunk-Royal, wo ich mit 20 Gästen schon liere. Das hast du quasi jede Woche. Und dementsprechend bedient man sich da auch logischerweise aus so einem festen Pool, wo man auch weiß, das funktioniert. Jetzt, wenn ich denen sage, um 9.20 Uhr, dann ist es auch um 9.20 Uhr.
Es gibt manchmal Härten, weil ich sehr gerne mit Jürgen Schmider und mit Heiko Ulldepp spreche. Das ist dann um 1.30 Uhr. Das war vor zwei Wochen so. Da war ich in Turin bei den ATP-Finals. Dann sitzt Schmider in Los Angeles, Ulldepp sitzt in Boston. Ich schreibe kurz in unsere Gruppe rein, hat jetzt jemand Zeit und das war dann um 1.30 Uhr in der frühen europäischen Zeit. Auch egal. Weil da auch immer was kommt. Auch gerade von Schmider, wer da mal reinhören möchte, der ist öfter in Las Vegas. Da reden wir dann halt über andere Dinge, wie dieses neue Sphere, ob man das jetzt mag oder nicht. Aber das finde ich halt spannend. Das kommt dann dazu rein zum Sport, den wir sowieso machen.
Und ich kann eben sagen, nachgewiesenermaßen, ich höre jede Big Show, du bist quasi, du bist mein Rettungsanker. Weil dadurch, dass ich so ein Fußball-Deb bin, kriege ich quasi im Fußball sehr viel mit. Na, es ist so. Aber in anderen Sportarten, für die ich mich eigentlich auch, also je nach Sportart unterschiedlich doll, aber ich interessiere mich eigentlich für einen Sport. Und du bist quasi mein Rettungsanker. Wenn etwas in der Big Show gesagt wurde, dann gibt es so eine 60% Chance, dass ich mich daran erinnere. Namen und so weiter werde ich immer alle vergessen haben, aber grob was passiert ist und alles andere läuft an mir vorbei. Also nur über dich kriege ich dann sowas wie DEL noch mit und eben Good American Football, MLB zum Beispiel. Und ich liebe es dann einfach, die MLB-Runde mit Axel Goldmann und wie heißt er?
Tom Heberlein.
Einfach fantastisch.
Ja, Axel ist auch so tief drinnen im Thema. Axel hat noch so eine emotionale Bindung zu den Boston Red Sox zum Beispiel. Das ist dann natürlich auch eine Geschichte, die...
Ist auch süß irgendwie.
Ja, die alle verbindet. Ich nehme Leute rein. Auch Thomas Wagner, der natürlich ein HSV-Fan ist. Und das macht ihn ja neben seinem gesamten gesammelten Wissen, das er hat und natürlich auch... Er bringt einfach was ein in die Show. Aber einfach dieses Wissen, dass er jedes Jahr mit dem HSV leidet. Und mittlerweile leide ich ja mit. Ich wünsche mir mittlerweile, ich weiß nicht, ob mir das jetzt die Hörer kostet, aber ich wünsche mir mittlerweile wirklich sehr. Ich wünsche mir, dass der HSV heute verliert gegen St. Pauli.
Das wünsche ich mir.
Damit beide aufsteigen. Genau. Also bitte den HSV in die Bundesliga. Das ist mein Plädoyer für den heutigen Donner.
Also Freitag haben wir heute. Man lernt auch tatsächlich bekannte Stimmen aus der Welt des Sports anders kennen. Also bei Toni Tomoc, da weiß ich jetzt eben welche niederen österreichischen Interessen er zum Beispiel auch hat und wie gut er sich im, was war es? Im Walisischen oder im Schottischen Fußball auskennt? Oder im Irischen?
Es ist glaube ich der Schottische. Toni hat mich gestern Abend gequält. Ich hab Sturm Graz gar nicht gesehen. Aber Toni hat mir 10 WhatsApp-Nachrichten geschrieben. Was ist los mit Sturm? Das ist halt die Mannschaft, die ich emotional verfolge immer noch. War heuer auch zwei, drei Mal sogar schon im Stadion in Graz, was immer schön ist. Und gestern Abend hatte ich mir meine Auszeit genommen, aber Toni Tomoc hat mich up to date gehalten über das Debakel, das ich in Graz abgespielt habe.
Na Gott sei Dank hat man solche Freunde.
Das ist doch schön zu wissen.
Also die Big Show, erscheinend jeden Donnerstag um 17 Uhr, ist nur eins von ganz vielen Formaten bei Sportradio360. Aber ich kann sie euch wirklich sehr empfehlen. Und weil du auch so ein Veteran bist, ich meine seit 2011, der Rasenfunk gibt es seit 2014. Ich nenne gegenüber anderen Podcastern, ist der Rasenfunk alt, aber wir verblassen alle.
Niemals älter als ich.
Nein, vor deiner Tradition. Ab einem gewissen Punkt muss man Alter um Münze in Tradition. Und das ist ja nur etwas Gutes, wenn wir den Fußball kennen. Aber deswegen kommst du auch noch quasi aus einer... Du hast quasi schon alles gesehen im Podcastbereich. Wir haben uns, bevor die Sendung lief, schon drüber unterhalten, wie sich es gerade verändert hat mit den ganzen Promis, die jetzt alle ihre Sportpodcasts haben. Und deine und auch meine Formate finden im Großteil dann gar nicht mehr statt. Man struggled auch so ein bisschen mit der Reichweite und so weiter. Und du bist aber auch, das ist mir neulich aufgefallen, du kennst ja auch Kai Pahl von Alles außer Sport wahrscheinlich noch sehr gut.
Kai hat meine Seite gebaut. Wer auf meine Seite gehen möchte, sportradio360.de, Kai Pahl hat sie gebaut, ja.
Und über Kai bin ich tatsächlich auch auf dich aufmerksam geworden, weil ich Alles außer Sport gelesen habe, so wie alle damals, sklavisch. Und da hat er immer nur geschrieben, ja, also die aktuelle Big Show hat wieder fast die 4-Stunden-Marke gerissen. Wir haben es nicht fast, wir haben es nicht. Und dann dachte ich mir, okay, warum findet er es immer so toll, dass es so lang ist? Und dann habe ich reingehört und seitdem höre ich tatsächlich. Und jetzt kommt aber die Pointe dazu. Also wir zwei, wir kennen den Kai Paar, ad-Docfood in allen sozialen Netzwerken, sind ihm sehr verbunden. Und neulich höre ich einen anderen Podcast, Becker und Pfeiffer, fantastischer Podcast. Mara Pfeiffer kennst du ja auch und Annika Becker. Und da hatte ihn Docfood eine Frage gestellt. Und so wie Annika das vorgelesen hat, hatte ich das Gefühl, ach krass, die kennt den Kai ja gar nicht. Weil die hat gesagt, ja, da hat uns noch ein ad-Docfood geschrieben. Und bei uns beiden wäre das größer Mensch, der Kai hätte sich gemeldet. Und das finde ich so schön, dass es quasi so Brücken gibt, zwischen der alten Welt, wo wir alles noch so independent gemacht haben und wo auch Podcast noch nicht so ein riesen Ding war, in die neue Welt hinein, wo auch neue Formate sich dann mit solchen Leuten, die einfach da geblieben sind, unterhalten. Kai ist irgendwann bei uns im Forum aufgetaucht. Ich habe mich so gefreut, dass der da mitkommetiert. Jetzt ist er auf dem Discord-Server auch noch vom Rasenfunk. Ist einfach schön. Und du bist quasi auch so eine Brücke für mich. Ja, deswegen gibt es nämlich quasi einmal jährlich diese Sendung, in der wir sagen, hört alle Sportradio360, hört die Big Show. Und du hast uns noch was mitgebracht, lieber Jens.
Ja, alle Jahre wieder. Nicht alle Jahre wieder. In diesem Jahr zum letzten Mal.
Jetzt wirklich?
Weiß ich noch nicht. Ich sage jedes Jahr, es wird das letzte Mal sein. Aber ich habe in diesem Jahr wieder und in dieser Sekunde kommt wahrscheinlich gerade die Spedition zu mir nach Hause und legt mir das Jahresmagazin von Sportradio360 vor die Haustür. Max, ich muss es dir, weil ich habe einen Dummy gebastelt, den zeige ich gleich, aber ich möchte euch das Cover hier zeigen. Es heißt 12 Monate und wenn man es denn sehen kann, Hashtag 12 Monate mit einem feinen ironischen Unterton, also das 2023 Jahr aus der Perspektive des wichtigsten Podcasts der Welt, der wir natürlich sind.
Ich finde die Ironie nicht.
Und ihr seht auf diesem Cover eine ganz, ganz bemerkenswerte junge Frau. Das ist Corrie Goff, die erstaunlicherweise es geschafft hat, dass sie in allen Weltranglisten mit ihrem Spitznamen geführt wird, mit Coco Goff. Das ist wie Zecke Neuendorf. Und angeblich ist Boris Becker auch Franz Boris Becker gewesen und man hat ihn nur Boris dann genannt, habe ich gelernt. Das ist unser Jahresmagazin, Sportradio360. Es gibt es jetzt zum vierten Mal. Ich durfte es bei dir Max schon dreimal bewerben. Es sind 84 Seiten geworden. Es sind 48 Journalisten, die dazu beigetragen haben. Ich freue mich sehr, weil niemand was dafür genommen hat. Wir kommen gleich zu den Details. Es sind ein paar meiner Säulenheiligen dabei, also Holger Gertz, vor allen Dingen von der Süddeutschen Zeitung, wo ich mich immer freue, Johannes Knuth von der Süddeutschen Zeitung, die Anna Dreher hat was geschrieben, Alex Feuerherd hat was geschrieben. Das sind Fußballthemen, aber nicht nur Fußballthemen, sondern eben auch, ja, Cory Goff ist kein Fußballthema. Ich hab wieder versucht, ich war wieder neugierig und hab auch so ein paar Rubriken, wer sind die Neukammer des Jahres, von denen, ich hab ein paar, also ich hab ein paar Leute, kannte ich gar nicht, die mir Marco Hagemann zum Beispiel vorgestellt hat. Oder auch Mark Heinrich hat mir eine junge Fußballerin vorgestellt, die unter meinem Radar gelaufen ist. Und das sind halt Dinge, die, deswegen hab ich es auch gemacht, weil ich es spannend finde.
Sehr, sehr gut. Und wie bekommen wir jetzt dieses Printprodukt?
Dieses Printprodukt hier, mit diesem Cover.
Dass es es noch nicht als Print gibt.
Es gibt es ab heute, gibt es als Printprodukt. Steilpass, also ihr schreibt mir bitte eine Mail, steilpassedsportradio360.de. Ganz wichtig angeben, die Versandadresse, wo das Teil hin soll. Wenn es heute kommt, dann wird es sofort in einen Briefumschlag reingepackt. Ich hab schon die Marken zu Hause, die Briefumschläge sind. Bei mir steilpassedsportradio360.de. Es kostet 12 Euro plus 1,60 Euro Versand. Und ich glaube, es ist es wert.
Also können die Leute aufrunden auf 15 Euro?
Sie können nicht nur, ich würde sagen ja. Das ist ein sehr schöner Gedanke, Max. Ein sehr schöner Gedanke, das dürft ihr gerne machen. Ihr könnt dann bezahlen, ihr bekommt eine Rechnung zugeschickt. Ihr könnt bezahlen per Überweisung, könnt aber auch bezahlen per Paypal. Überhaupt kein Problem.
Steilpasset sportradio360.de Die wichtigste Frage, bevor wir ein bisschen reingucken und du uns ein bisschen was vorstellen kannst, ist die Frage nach dem Warum, Jens. Vor allem, weil du ja jedes Jahr sagst, ah, das war jetzt wirklich das letzte Mal.
Okay, weil es mich irgendwann im September dann plötzlich quält. Ja, da sitze ich dann in New York bei den US Open. Mir ist langweilig, weil die zweite Woche ist halt nicht so viel los. Und dann sitze ich dort in diesem National Tennis Center, das großartig ist, wo ich gerne bin. Das ist das Highlight meines Jahres jedes Jahr. Und denke mir, soll ich es wieder machen? Und dann frage ich mal den ersten. In diesem Jahr war es so, ich habe Stefan Koch gefragt. Also wer Stefan Koch kennt, Magenta Sport, ist Basketball-Coach gewesen, früh in der BBL. Und hat dort jetzt auch seine Kolumne auf Magenta Sport. Und ich rufe den Stefan an, sag Stefan, ich überlege mir, mir ein Magazin zu machen. Hättest du eventuell Lust, über dieses Thema zu schreiben? Sag, da mach ich gerne. So, einen Tag später kommt von Stefan Koch schon dieser Text zu mir. Und dann denk ich mir, ok, jetzt kann ich nicht mehr zurück. Und dann fängt es da oben zu arbeiten an. Und ich sage, ok, wen könnte ich jetzt noch anhauen? Und allein die Idee, also ich lese was Holger schreibt in der Süddeutschen, lese ich sklavisch und dann fragst du den Holger, könntest du vielleicht und dann ist sowieso schon geschehen um mich. Und dann gehe ich halt meine Liste durch und überlege mir, was könnte ich anders machen als beim letzten Mal? Beim letzten Mal, vielleicht kommen wir noch drauf, hatte ich ein reines Interviewmagazin. Habe ich auch gut gefunden, weil ich da Leute hatte, an die ich normalerweise nicht rankomme. Oliver Seidel hat dort, Oliver Seidel diesmal auch dabei, Oliver Seidel hat damals mit Dieter Schatzenschneider gesprochen. Für mich immer noch das Highlight. Einfach weil auch Schatzschneider halt wirklich kann man jetzt mögen, Mann der alten Schule kann man nicht mögen, aber unterhaltsam fand ich das schon. Und dieses Mal habe ich wieder ein paar Features drinnen, größere Features, und habe aber auch so kleinere Rubriken wie eben die Neuankömmlinge. Dann habe ich auch eine Rubrik, für wen es in diesem Jahr überhaupt nicht gut gelaufen, wen sollte man unbedingt auf seinem Radar haben, hat man aber nicht, weil es vielleicht ein kleines bisschen drunter läuft. Der hat Jonas Friedrich zum Beispiel mir was geschrieben. Also irgendwann packt es mich und dann ist irgendwann der Punkt erreicht, wo ich nicht mehr zurück kann. Eben in dem Moment, wo Stefan Koch mir seine ersten zwei Texte schickt, ich kann nicht mehr. Ich kann nicht mehr zurück.
Gut, dass er das gemacht hat. Den solltest du immer als erstes anfragen. Deswegen gibt es eben ein unabhängig hergestelltes Sportmagazin mit eben vielen bekannten Namen drin.
Ich habe es wie jedes Jahr selbst drucken lassen, bei einer deutschen Druckerei. Das teuerste sind immer die Bilder am Ende des Tages. Ich muss Bildrechte einkaufen, weil ohne Bilder macht das Ganze keinen Spaß. Netterweise haben mich manche Vereine unterstützt, wo ich hingeschrieben habe, zum Beispiel nach Eisenach in die Handball-Bundesliga mit Fotos. Dann die Chemnitzer Basketballer und auch Sturm Graz. Es gibt einen Newcomer von Sturm Graz, den mir Martin Konrad beschrieben hat. Aber das habe ich alles selbst finanziert und würde mich natürlich freuen, wenn ihr zuschlagt. Ich weiß, der Maxi-Power des Rasenfunk ist Wahnsinn. Die letzten Jahre hat das auch fantastisch funktioniert.
Enttäuscht mich nicht, liebe Leute. Bisher war es oft so, dass der Rasenfunk da viel geholfen hat. Man muss eben sagen, du bist da ins Risiko gegangen. Du musst alles vorfinanzieren und wenn das jetzt nicht gekauft wird, dann hast du ein Problem.
Weil ich auch mit Gas heize und nicht mit Holz. Sonst könnte ich...
Und wir müssen auch noch heizen, weil das Wetter so ist. Es ist einfach ein Debakel, liebe Leute da draußen.
Ich finde es gar nicht schlecht, dass wir jetzt Winter haben.
Zur Abwechslung. Die Kinder, die haben draußen schon gebaut, im Garten kann ich dir später zeigen, die fanden das auch ganz fantastisch.
Mein Hund findet das auch toll.
Ich suche panisch die Schneehosen der Kinder.
Du hast wenigstens noch welche für die Kinder. Ich bräuchte selbst einen.
Ich fürchte, die sind schon wieder rausgewachsen. Aber gut, bevor ich jetzt auch noch um Support für den Rasenfunk-Battle gib uns doch mal einen kleinen Einblick. Was kann man alles so finden?
Wir haben eben, lass mich wirklich, ich weiß, wir kommen auch zum Fußball, aber lass mich wirklich mit Corey Goff beginnen. Corey Goff, das ist der Spread, geschrieben hat es Klaus Bellstedt. Klaus Bellstedt ist beim Spiegel. Klaus Bellstedt hat gerade ein sehr, sehr interessantes Stück geschrieben über Alexander Zverev. Sehr, sehr schwierige Geschichte gerade mit Alexander Zverev. Er hat für den Stern geschrieben, aber Klaus war in New York auch dabei. Und Corey Goff ist, das kann man nicht hoch genug aufhängen, sie wird, sie muss das Frauentennis alleine retten. Es ist tatsächlich so. Warum? Diese junge Frau, du möchtest am liebsten zu ihren Eltern gehen und etwas zu schreiben dabei haben, oder zumindest das Aufnahmegerät. Und die Eltern fragen, wie habt ihr diese Tochter erzogen, dass die so geworden ist, wie sie ist, wenn du in Pressekonferenzen von Corey Goff gehst, das ist eine Offenbarung, und zwar wirklich im positiven Sinne. Weil du kannst ja vergleichen mit anderen, vor allen Dingen Spielerinnen, aber auch Spielern. Da kommt zum Großteil nichts. Nichts. Und bei Corey Goff kommt alles. Es ist dafür, dass diese Frau erst 19 Jahre alt ist, die ist als 15-Jährige auf die Tour gekommen, hat damals Venus Williams geschlagen in Wimbledon, alle sofort ganz narrisch geworden. Aber so einfach geht es dann auch nicht im Tennissport, dass du dann was Großes gewinnst. Und die Pressekonferenzen mit ihr sind Wahnsinn. Du kannst sie alles fragen, sie hat auf alles. Sie denkt kurz nach, manchmal denkt sie auch nicht kurz nach, sondern hat sofort die Antwort. Ganz typisch in diesem Jahr bei den US Open, sie spielt das Halbfinale gegen Karolina Muchova. Ganz, ganz enges Match, Muchova ist eine wunderbare Tennisspielerin. Und es gibt ihm dann Leute, es gab Leute in den USA, war das noch nicht bekannt, es hat sich jemand festgeklebt. Auf der Tribüne hat protestiert, also wie wir es hier ja auch kennen, wie man jetzt dazu steht, spielt überhaupt keine Rolle. Das Spiel musste unterbrochen werden. Und Goff hat das Spiel dann gewonnen. Und wurde natürlich in der Pressekonferenz danach gefragt, ja, also wie war das jetzt für sie, dass das Spiel unterbrochen wurde? Und sie sagt, okay, auf der einen Seite ist es natürlich sportlich gesehen für mich schwierig gewesen, weil ich muss mein Spiel unterbrechen. Aber auf der anderen Seite kann ich mich nicht hinsetzen und immer den friedlichen Protest fordern und dann sagen, was derjenige da gemacht hat, das finde ich nicht gut. Und das muss erst mal von der 19-Jährigen kommen. Eine halbe Stunde, nachdem sie dieses Spiel dann auch gewonnen hat. Wenn sie verloren hätte, hätte sie, glaube ich, das Gleiche gesagt. So viel traue ich ihr zu. Und meine große Sorge war, weil ich vorhin gesagt habe, sie muss den Frauen-Tennis-Sport retten, dass sie nicht gut genug ist, spielerisch. Also als Person ist sie über jeden Zweifel, aber Corrie Goff hat leider, das kann sogar ich feststellen, sie hat technische Schwächen, die es zu kaschieren galt und gilt. Sie ist athletisch unfassbar gut. Ich möchte jetzt nicht zu nerdig werden, aber es gibt die Nummer 1 der Welt, Iga Świontek aus Polen, die ist athletisch auf einem Level mit Steffi Graf, das haben wir seitdem nicht mehr gesehen, unfassbar gut. Und Corrie Goff ist fast dort, spielt aber nicht so gut Tennis. Und jetzt hat sie aber, und das hat der Klaus eben hier auch erfasst, jetzt hat sie vor den US Open die Idee gehabt, ich nehme mir Brad Gilbert in mein Team. Und Brad Gilbert, wer sich ein bisschen für Tennis interessiert, winning ugly, also nicht immer ganz schön, was er macht. Aber Brad Gilbert hat mit ihr einen Weg gefunden, wie sie eben dieses Turnier gewonnen hat. Und das war so wahnsinnig wichtig, nicht für sie selbst, nicht nur für sie selbst, für sie selbst auch. Aber für den Tennis-Sport, das Corrie Goff dieses Turnier gewinnt, die US Open, Spoiler Alert. Aber der Klaus schreibt ihm darüber, wer es weiß, hat es mitbekommen. Und es war unfassbar wichtig für den Tennis-Sport, weil das Frauentennis hat ein Aufmerksamkeitsproblem. Die Männer erzählen, ob es gute Geschichten sind, weiß ich nicht, aber die erzählen Geschichten. Und das Frauentennis braucht, es kommt zum Glück Anfang 2024 Nohmi Osaka zurück, die eine ganz andere Persönlichkeit ist als Corrie Goff, aber auch unfassbar spannend. Und die natürlich auch mit ihrer japanischen Herkunft, aber eigentlich wird es ja auch so als halbe Amerikanerin wahrgenommen, unfassbar wichtig für den Frauensport, dass die zurückkommt. Und es wäre wunderschön, wenn auch Emma Raducanu die 2021 in New York gewonnen hat. Die junge Britin, die leider, hat sie 2021 oder 2022 gewonnen? 22 glaube ich, nee 21. Anyway, junge Engländerin, die leider sehr, sehr oft verletzt ist, aber auch sehr charismatisch. Also diese Leute braucht es, aber am vordersten Front ist Corrie Goff und der Klaus hat darüber geschrieben.
Freue ich mich sehr drauf, denn man hört es ja, also der Tennis-Teil, man hat es vielleicht ganz leicht gemerkt. Das ist eine Leidenschaft von dir. Minimal wird man es vielleicht gemerkt haben. Und da ist es aber eben ganz oft so, dass ihr darüber sprecht, ja hier, Dame Tennis, wer könnt's werden, dann werft ihr vier, fünf Namen rein, die ich dann immer wieder erkenne, mir aber nicht alle merken kann. Aber es ist eben, es ist nicht diese große Rivalität, die du eben jetzt hattest mit den großen drei, die ganz lange im Männertennis mit dabei waren, die jetzt herausgefordert werden von anderen, die nachkommen. Aber Djokovic drohend noch über allen. Und das kann auch so ein Fußball-Deb wie ich quasi gerade aus dem Kopf nacherzählen. Und früher über den Stand der Williams-Schwestern, konnte ich dir aber ganz gut sagen, sind die gerade in der Weltspitze mit dabei, ist eine von beiden verletzt, weil irgendwie das auch bei mir hängen geblieben ist, weil genügend darüber berichtet wurde. Und das fehlt aktuell so ein bisschen.
Ja, Serena Williams hat ein großes Vakuum hinterlassen. Also ich verstehe zu 0%, welcher Hass teilweise Serena Williams entgegengeschleudert wird. Serena Williams ist eine Ikone, wahrscheinlich die größte Sportlerin. Und da können wir gerne die Sportler mit reinnehmen, aller Zeiten. Was sie wirklich, wie sie aufgewachsen ist, was sie durchmachen musste. Natürlich jeder Spitzensportler, jeder Musiker auch, finde ich, der der Welt berühmt geworden. Ist. Eine der ganz großen Ikonen des Tennis-Sports, aber auch des Sports generell, Billie Jean King ist in diesem Jahr geehrt worden bei den US Open, weil es eben seit 20 Jahren, glaube ich, Equal Price Money gibt bei den US Open. Und da gibt es eben diesen Spruch, Pressure is a Privilege. Und manche zerbrechen an diesem Druck. Und auch Serena Williams hat sicherlich Situationen gehabt, wo man gemerkt hat, dieser Druck nagt an ihr. Aber das ist eine, die sie über jeden Zweifel haben, Serena Williams, weil sie eben auch als dunkelhäutige Sportlerin natürlich Probleme hatte, von denen wir überhaupt nichts ahnen können. Und die hat aber auch den Weg gebannt eben für Leute wie Corey Goff, die auch zu diesem Thema unheimlich viel weiß und sagt.
Ich überlege die ganze Zeit, wie die Dokumentation hieß, die ich in diesem Jahr über die Williams-Schwestern gesehen habe.
Hast du vielleicht den Spielfilm gesehen? King Richard?
Nee, den habe ich eben nicht gesehen. Aber es gab eine Dokumentation, ich glaube, ich habe die in irgendeiner Mediathek einfach gesehen und dann angemacht. Vielleicht bei Arte sogar, auch wenn das jetzt so klingt, als ob ich immer Arte gucken würde, ist nicht so oft.
Ständig, ständig. Das ist das zweite auf Marks Podcastliste. Der erste, einzige Sportradio360 und das nächste ist dann Arte.
Wieder zum Runterkommen. Quasi das Niveau von Sportradio360, das ist mir oft zu hoch. Und dann Arte zum Runterkommen noch ein bisschen. Nee, aber da wurde eben auch beschrieben, wie eben damals Serena, glaube ich in Texas, das erste WTA- oder ATP-Turnier gewinnt gegen eine US-Amerikanerin. Und sie wird ausgeboot vom natürlich mehrheitlich weißen Publikum dafür, dass sie das gewonnen hat. Völlig verdient, sportlich verdient, also absolut.
Ja, aber das zieht sich ja durch alle Sportarten, auch in den USA. Wenn du siehst die NBA, wer spielt auf dem Court, das sind zu 60% wahrscheinlich dunklerhäutige Sportler. Das gleiche beim Tennis, aber wer sitzt im Publikum? Das sind dann so 95% Leute, die sich die Karten leisten können. Und es ist halt leider diese Diskrepanz. Und deshalb umso wichtiger. Serena und Venus Williams waren natürlich Role Models für jüngere afroamerikanische Sportlerinnen und Sportler. Bei den Männern gibt es mit Francis Tier vor einen, der in der Weltspitze mitspielt, der auch ein super Typ ist. Man schaut wirklich gerne zu. Aber Coco Goff ist jetzt nochmal die jüngere Generation. Und die ist so schlau und so großartig. Deshalb habe ich sie gerne und diesmal auch solo auf den Titel genommen.
Ja, das ist mir schon aufgefallen, dass du diesmal nur eine Sportlerin auf dem Titel hast. Und das finde ich sehr, sehr positiv. Aber es gibt ja nicht nur Tennis in diesem Magazin. Also du wirst uns jetzt nicht hier alles vorstellen können.
Aber lass mich noch zu einem alten, weißen Mann kommen. Endlich. Weil ich ja auch zumindest demografisch hoffe. Ich hoffe nur demografisch, manchmal vielleicht auch rhetorisch, aber nur demografisch in diese Riege fallen. Wir kommen auch gleich zum Fußball. Aber Gordon Herbert, der Nationaltrainer des deutschen Basketball-Nationalteams, den ich in der Easy Credit BBL, heißt jetzt früher Beko BBL, öfter mal gesehen habe, an der Seitenlinie in Frankfurt noch Coach war und ich mir gedacht habe, ok, ein bisschen zerstreuter Professor und dann wird Gordon Herbert Bundestrainer. Ich dachte mir, weil ich mich auch nicht auskenne, ist das jetzt eine Verlegenheitslösung oder hat kein anderer die Hand hochgehoben und habe mich dann aber erst damit beschäftigt, was Gordon Herbert alles davor gemacht hat. Und dann kommt in diesem Sommer und ich glaube, dass auch ihr da draußen dir vielleicht dem Fußball mehr anhängt. Aber dieser Run beginnt mit der deutschen Basketball-Nationalmannschaft im Sommer und das ist eine Truppe gewesen, die, wo mir davor schon gesagt wurde von meinen Experten, ja, die haben eine Medaillen-Chance. Und natürlich denkst du dir immer, die Amerikaner werden wahrscheinlich die Favoriten sein, die sind aber nicht ganz mit der stärksten Mannschaft gekommen. Nichts ist ein Paris wird es anders sein bei Olympia, aber die Deutschen sind eben dahingefahren und die Deutschen haben in ihrer Mannschaft einen so eindeutigen Leader und das finde ich auch wieder stark. Das ist Dennis Schröder, ganz einfach. Dennis Schröder ist jemand, wenn du meine Basketballleute fragst, die viel tiefer drinnen sind. Dennis hat nicht immer diese Anführerrolle gut ausgefüllt, aber bei dieser Weltmeisterschaft und vor der Weltmeisterschaft schon, hat er das gigantisch gut gemacht. Das hat mir Stefan Koch auch erklärt. Da gab es, ich möchte nicht zu detailliert werden, aber es gab eben mit Maxi Kleber, ein sehr, sehr guter Spieler von der Dallas Mavericks. Und Dennis hat im Grunde genommen gesagt, Maxi, du hast letztes Jahr nicht mitgespielt bei der EM, wir brauchen dich jetzt nicht. Ja, und da habe ich eben dann auch Stefan Koch gefragt bei mir in der Sendung. Ja, und da gibt es jetzt die Autorität von Gordon Herbert. Und da war sich Stefan nicht ganz sicher. Und wie sich dann bei der WM gezeigt hat, die deutsche Nationalmannschaft hat ja einen knappen Sieg nach dem anderen gefeiert. Und das Großartige war zum einen, dass man immer mehr dran geglaubt hat, aber wenn Dennis einen schlechten Tag gehabt hat, dass ihn wirklich seine Mannschaftskameraden da rausgezogen haben. Franz Wagner zum Beispiel, der auch über große Teile der WM verletzt war. Franz Wagner, der jetzt eine gigantisch gute Saison spielt für die Orlando Magic. Ich muss dir mal vorstellen, jemand der Franz heißt. Im Jahr 2023 ist das großartig, ja. Also ich find's fantastisch. Ja, und Gordon Herbert ist eben der Coach dieser Mannschaft gewesen. Und ist es immer noch, wollte jetzt im Herbst für eine französische Mannschaft nebenbei noch den Head Coach geben in der Euro League. Wurde ihm vom Deutschen Basketball Bund nicht erlaubt. Und das ist Gordy. Wer Gordy nicht kennt, das ist Gordon Herbert hier mit dem WM-Pokal. Ja, und man sieht, wer sich freut. Und gleich im Editorial habe ich noch ein Bild von ihm, das fand ich großartig, dass er nach diesem WM-Sieg erschöpft. Genau. Ja, und was gibt's über Gordon Herbert in diesem Heft? Es gibt das einzige Interview. Das hat Sepp Dumitru gemacht, Sepp Dumitru war dabei bei der WM, ist am Ende dem deutschen Team nachgereist, war davor in Indonesien und hat sich andere Mannschaften angeschaut und war aber dann ab dem Viertelfinale mit dem deutschen Team auch unterwegs. Und Sepp hat mit Coach Herbert gesprochen und ganz, ganz spannend, weil er eben auch beschreibt, wie dieses Team gewachsen ist und welche Idee sie gehabt haben, diesen Prozess, dass dieser Prozess aber jetzt auch noch nicht abgeschlossen ist, eben mit dem Weltmeistertitel, sondern nächstes Jahr Olympia und nächstes Jahr Olympia wird die Konkurrenz um einiges größer sein. Aber das ist halt, was ich an euch Deutschen so schätze oder schätzte früher auch als Fußball-Nation, dass man mit der Aufgabe gewachsen ist. Mittlerweile hat man den Eindruck, dass man mit der Aufgabe ein kleines bisschen schrumpft, egal ob das jetzt die Frauen-Nationalmannschaft ist oder die Männer-Nationalmannschaft.
Oder Klimawandel oder Tempolimit.
Ja, man schrumpft leider auch mit der Anschaffung von Wärmepumpen. Man schrumpft mittlerweile mit der Aufgabe, leider. Aber dieses Team ist gewachsen. Und noch mal, und Sepp hat eben mit Gordi, ich hab's einfach nur Gordi genannt, diesen Artikel, weil alle, bis auf mich, dürfen zu ihm Gordi sagen. Also offenbar in der Basketballbranche ist es so Gordi, der auch selbst eine bewegte Geschichte hat. Ich find's fantastisch. Ich hab auch noch mal den deutschen WM-Kader hier eingefügt, weil man eben sieht, es kommen Leute zusammen, die in der EuroLeague spielen, die in der deutschen Liga spielen. Die deutsche Liga hatte den Anspruch, dass sie die beste Liga Europas wird. Es hätte bis 2022 werden sollen, ist aber unrealistisch. Woran misst man das? Man misst an den EuroLeague-Erfolgen. Und da ist Deutschland halt leider, auch wenn der FC Bayern München viel Geld investiert, sind sie zu weit weg. Aber das ist ein Basketball-Teil mit Gordy, den ich wärmstens ans Herz legen kann.
Seit der WM ja tatsächlich. Ich werde ja oft Max-Jacob Obst genannt. Sowohl in Live-Produktion. Und seit dieser WM empfinde ich das als Kompliment, als Herr Obst bezeichnet zu werden. Und gleichzeitig fand ich, also du hast dieses Bild ja auch von Gordy Herbert mit drin, wie er so erschöpft ist danach, auch total unterschätztes Thema. Wir haben es bei Gordy Herbert gesehen. Wir haben es jetzt bei Martina Vosteklenburg erlebt. Es gibt durchaus auch Bundesligatrainer, die ihren Job jetzt abgegeben haben, von denen ich schon gehört habe. Ähnliche Gründe könnten da zumindest mit reingespielt haben. Diese Erschöpfung im Job, im Leistungssport als Trainer und dann besonders bei solchen Turnieren, wo ja dann Benni Zander, also überhaupt die Coverage bei Magenta Sport war ganz fantastisch, aber wo Benni Zander dann nach dem Spiel gegen die USA, Halbfinale war das, dann zu Gordon Herbert sagt, ja aber vielleicht jetzt nicht gleich heute Nacht wieder drei Spiele analysieren, vielleicht reichen ja diesmal nur zwei. Er sagt es so als Scherz und da siehst du, wie absurd eigentlich das ist, das was die da vor Ort leisten. Und das finde ich halt insofern relevant, weil jetzt bei Gordon Herbert haben wir es gesehen, bei Martina Vosteklenburg wissen wir es, weil sie es gesagt hat, aber wir haben das ja auch bei Hansi Flick bei der WM in Katar gehabt oder wir haben das bei Joachim Löw 2018 in Russland gehabt. Und da wird halt nur nicht drüber geredet, weil halt einfach diese Turniere so erfolglos waren und weil das auch mit am Trainer lag. Aber dennoch haben die ja alles gegeben, was sie hatten. Das gerät mir manchmal so ein bisschen in Vergessenheit.
Mein Lieblingspodcast ist nach wie vor, obwohl ich jetzt keine Zeit mehr, aber relativ wenig Zeit mehr habe das reinzunehmen.
Der Rasenfunk.
Das ist der Rasenfunk A, aber 1A ist The Dan Lebertard Show with Stu Guts aus Miami und die hatten Stan Van Gundy, früher Coach in der NBA, öfter als Gast. Und der hat das mal beschrieben, diesen Druck. Der war im NBA-Coach für die Orlando Magic zum Beispiel. Und der hat gesagt, wenn ich ein Spiel verloren habe, ist sowieso der ganze Abend im Eimer. Weil ich muss dann analysieren, warum habe ich verloren und habe natürlich diesen Druck, ich darf das nächste Spiel nicht verlieren. Und dann fragt dem Dan, ja was, Stan, wenn du gewonnen hast, was ist dann? Ist es gleich schlimm? Weil ich könnte das nächste Spiel verlieren. Das heißt, diese 82 Spiele des Grunddurchgangs in der NBA und dann natürlich noch viel mehr in den Playoffs, dieser Druck, der auf Tränen lastet, ist enorm. Und weil du Martina von Stecklenburg ansprichst, Anna Dreher von der Süddeutschen Zeitung, auch in diesem Heft hat über MVT geschrieben, ich weiß gar nicht, ob das addiktiv interessant ist, aber ich finde es schon interessant, wie sich das entwickelt hat nach dieser WM mit dieser Absenz.
Ja, es ist absurd.
Und da muss wieder Horst Rubisch ran. Wenn alle Stricke reißen, muss der Horst ran.
Ja, genau. Und gleichzeitig ist es auch ein ganz guter Reminder dafür, wir machen immer alles an sportlichen Ergebnissen fest. Weil klar, das ist ja auch die Währung im Sport. Und es ist Leistungssport. Und dann zählt es ja auch, wie weit jemand gekommen ist. Aber das deutsche Frauen-Nationalteam ist das perfekte Beispiel geradefür. Als man ins EM-Finale gekommen ist, und eigentlich wäre Alex Popp nicht verletzt gewesen, hätte man das glaube ich auch gewonnen. Und es gab auch eine klare Fehlentscheidung gegen Deutschland. Rote Karte und Handspiel auf der eigenen Linie beim Stand von 0-0 hätte einen Strafstoß geben müssen. Es war damals nicht alles so toll, wie es aussah. Es ist aber auch jetzt nicht alles so schlecht, wie es jetzt aussieht. Und dann ist es halt so ganz schwierig, immer diese Nuance dazwischen zu finden. Weil nach außen hin war die WM ein Desaster. War sie insgesamt auch sportlich gesehen. Aber du kannst es eben ganz gut erklären mit Dingen, die du auch schon bei der EM gesehen hast. Und dafür brauchst du aber Zeit und Platz. Und die Anna, die hat den Platz dann in der Süddeutschen Zeitung. Und andere auch. Aber wir eben in unseren Formaten haben diesen Raum eben auch. Und das ist das, was für mich, deswegen informiere ich mich ja über andere Sportarten, über die Big Show. Weil ich eben weiß, ich kriege da. Und da dauert dann das Segment. In der Regel ist es eine Viertelstunde. Aber wenn ihr was Wichtiges habt und euch festredet, zum Beispiel Napoleon von Ridley Scott. Nee, aber dann geht es eben auch mal länger. Und dann höre ich eben auch manchmal Dinge, wo ich vielleicht gar nicht einer Meinung bin. Also ich kann mich noch an eine Diskussion erinnern. Ich weiß sogar noch genau, wo ich da war. Ich habe es auf dem Fahrrad gehört in München. Jürgen Schmider, Heiko Ulldorp und du über Saudi-Arabien und den Einfluss im Fußball. Und da hat Jürgen ein paar Dinge gesagt, wo ich mir gedacht habe, Mensch krass, okay, sehe ich gerade komplett anders. Da hätte ich am liebsten angehalten auf dem Fahrrad. Aber ich habe bis heute diesen Gedanken manchmal drin und überprüfe manchmal meine eigenen Überlegungen zu diesem Thema mit Dingen, die er damals gesagt hat. Und das passiert mir nur bei Podcasts.
Ja, ja, auch Situationen, weil du immer am Rauters hörst, wo du... Ganz, ganz schwierige Thematik übrigens, ja. Und da muss man mit Jonas Friedrich auch darüber reden. Ich tue mich extrem schwer.
Der Lift-Tour und so.
Ja, in dem Moment finden dort gerade die Next-Gen-Finals heißt das, der Jahresabschluss der acht besten U21-Spiele im Tennis, statt kein Mensch im Publikum. Es sind mehr Betreuer als Zuschauer dort. Aber natürlich haben die Saudis so viel Geld hingelegt, dass die ATP gesagt hat, ja, das machen wir. Ist uns doch wurscht, ob da jemand zuschaut oder nicht. Und das wird uns halt auch 2034 bei der Fußball-WM dann drohen. Ja, sind schwierige Themen.
Ja gut, aber sie müssen ja diskutiert werden und dafür eignet sich das Podcast-Format. Und wie schön, dass du Gordy Herbert in deinem Heft drin hast. Das ist schon echt krass, dass du so independent ein Magazin auf die Beine stellst. Und es war ja im letzten Jahr auch so, wir sollten später auch nochmal kurz über das letztjährige Heft sprechen. Aber dass du dann immer solche Perlen mit drin hast.
Ja, ich weiß auch nicht. Ich hab ein gutes Telefonbuch mittlerweile. Und wer bei drei nicht auf dem Baum ist, der macht dann noch was. Ja, Alex Feuerherd ist auch so jemand. Wir bringen kurz die Kurve zum Fußball. Und zwar hat Alex Feuerherd über, ihr kennt sie natürlich, Stephanie Frappard gesprochen. Immer die Erste, überall die Erste. Und wir sehen hier unten, ja, also sie hat Costa Rica gegen Deutschland gepfiffen bei der Fußball-WM 2021, ne, 2022 war es, in Katar. Und ja, der Alex ist natürlich bei Schiedsrichter-Themen, jetzt auch beruflich, wie wir wissen, ganz, ganz tief drinnen und hat eben diese Frau beschrieben, die aus verschiedenen Gründen spannend ist. Alfred Tata, ein lieber Freund aus Österreich, wer es kennt bei Sky Austria, ist ein bisschen der verrückte Professor dort, oder nicht der verrückte, sondern der zerstreute Professor, so ist besser. Und er hat mir mal gesagt, Jens, weißt du, wenn du im Jahr 2023 bei einer Fußballmannschaft Trainer bist, bei einer Bundesligamannschaft, du musst fast 1,85, 1,90 groß sein, weil du einfach diese Autorität, und du kannst, und der Alphard ist leider nicht 1,95 groß, sondern eher 1,70. Und wenn ich mir jetzt Stephanie Frappard anschaue, die ja nicht so groß ist, dann ist er zusätzlich zu allen anderen Dingen, aber hier sieht man sie ganz gut.
Zeig es mal im Vergleich zu Manuel Neuer, da kann man das fast noch ein bisschen besser sehen.
Ja, genau, zu Manuel Neuer, das ist natürlich ganz, ganz ausgezeichnet. Ja, also diese Autorität, die man dann zusätzlich noch mitbringen muss mit dem anderen Gepäck, das finde ich unheimlich spannend. Und Alex beschreibt ihm hier, wie ich finde, in wunderbaren und verständnisvollen Worten auch, wie es soweit gekommen ist. Und das ist auch ein ganz, ganz spannendes Thema. Ich habe sowieso bei mir jetzt in diesem Heft festgestellt, dass ich relativ viele Offizielle, wenn man Trainer als Offizielle nimm, mit eben Martina von Stecklenburg, mit Stephanie Frappard, aber auch mit Goldie Herbert, mit Frank Baumann, wo Holger Gertzmaß darüber geschrieben hat. Also es ist ein Mix aus wirklich aktiven Sportlern und auch dann aber auf der anderen Seite eben auch eigene Rubrik über Trainer. Und das finde ich eben als Fußballthema spannend. Ich finde auch spannend, was Holger Gertz, der ja, und das ist ja das Schöne auch, ja jeder hat seine Schwäche und die Schwäche von Holger ist Werder Bremen. Und wie alle Werder Bremen Fans wahrscheinlich, ich bin Bremen ja auch sehr zugetan. Wir trauern ja alle den großen Zeiten nach, als damals Diego von der Mittellinie den Ball ins Tor gehoben hat und Klaus Bellstedt, Titelgeschichte, Klaus Bellstedt großer Bremen Fan, hat seinen Sohn, der erst drei Monate alt ist oder vier Monate, mindestens mit dem zweiten Namen, ich meine aber sogar mit dem ersten Namen Johann genannt, mit einem N natürlich nur wegen Johann Miku. Und das finde ich halt auch schön, dass alle Leute, die da drinnen sind, eine mindestens, ich habe mehrere Schwächen, aber mindestens eine Schwäche haben und diese dann auch offen zugeben und ausleben gewissermaßen.
Und so kommt dann eben auch ein Franz wieder in die MBA. Das kann ja nur der Kaiser gewesen sein.
Das kann nur der Kaiser gewesen sein. Die Familie Wagner, was weiß man schon. Da müsste man die Eltern mal fragen.
Und jeder hat so seine Schwäche, die werden in diesem Heft offen gelegt und deine Schwäche ist, diese Hefte zu machen. Jetzt schon zum vierten Mal und es soll eben Erfolg haben. Also legt das euch selbst unter den Weihnachtsbaum, legt das anderen unter den Weihnachtsbaum. Es ist eine wunderbare Lektüre und wir können sogar, jetzt nicht gratis, aber wir können noch was drauflegen, denn wir haben noch welche von letztem Jahr.
Nochmal, also steilpassedsportradio360.de schreibt mir eine Mail mit eurer Adresse, wo es hingehen soll. 12 Euro plus 1,60 Euro Versand. Die deutsche Post ist seit dem letzten Mal um 5 Cent teurer geworden. Ja, das, da habe ich noch ein paar herumliegen bei mir zu Hause.
Das ist jetzt kein Dummy, sondern das ist das tatsächliche Produkt.
Da hat meine Druckerei rechtzeitig geliefert. Das ist zwölf Monate aus dem Jahr 2020, aber es ist zeitlos. Es sind, wenn ihr hier seht, apropos Leidenschaft, dieser junge Mann hat 1987 Boris Becker als Wimbledon-Sieger abgelöst. Das ist Pat Cash. Pat Cash habe ich damals zufällig beim Turnier in Ismaning getroffen und habe gesagt, hätten sie eine Minute Zeit für mich. Das muss man sich mal vorstellen. Es hat gleiche Temperaturen gehabt wie heute. Es hat geschneit, ich eingemürmelt, Pat Cash im T-Shirt. Und wir fangen so zu reden und reden und reden und reden. Und mitten im Interview geht er plötzlich weg von mir. Und hat sich nicht mehr vorabschiedet, hat einfach gegangen. Aber egal, ich habe genug aus ihm herausgesaugt für dieses Interview, wo es um Legenden geht. Und hier ist eben auch drinnen dieses Interview von Oliver Seidler mit Dieter Schatzschneider. Es geht um Coaches, es geht um Trainer generell. Und Dieter Schatzschneider hat ja zwei Trainer gehabt, die gigantisch waren. Der eine ist Ernst Happel, den ich ja auch verehre. Obwohl man wahrscheinlich das, was Ernst Happel damals gemacht hat, jetzt sehr, sehr kritisch hinterfragen würde. Also extrem kritisch. Aber geben wir mal einen Benefit of the doubt. Ja, trennen wir Werk von Personen, wie es auch gern gemacht wird. Und der andere war Adi Pinter. Adi Pinter, komplett geistesgestörter, darf man glaube ich, Posthum noch sagen, oder sagen wir einen Mann mit eigenen Methoden. So möchte ich es formulieren. Adi Pinter war damals Trainer beim Grazer Athletiker Club, beim GRK, wo auch Klaus Augenthaler später dann Trainer war. Und ich bin dem GRK nicht freundschaftlich verbunden, weil ich bin Sturm Graz freundschaftlich verbunden. Große Rivalität, dennoch, Max, ich hoffe, der GRK führt die zweite Liga an. Also ich hoffe wirklich fast noch mehr, als dass der HSV aufsteigt, dass der GRK aufsteigt. Ich war am 2. November im Grazer Stadion, Sturm gegen GRK, Pokal, Achtelfinale. Sturm hat nicht unverdient, aber am Ende dann doch glücklich mit 3-2 gewonnen. Stadion war voll, das war wunderschön, die Hälfte rot. Na, sagen wir mal ein Drittel rot, die zweite, zwei Drittel schwarz, weil Sturm eben doch der platzische ist. Es war großartig. Ja, und Adi Pinter war eben Trainer von Dieter Schatzschneider in Graz. Und das wird so wunderbar beschrieben da. Dieter Schatzschneider, Rekordtor, Schütze bis vor kurzem in der 2. Liga, dann hat den Simon Terode überholt. Und Schatzschneider kommt als Superstar dorthin. Und Adi Pinter möchte ihm irgendwas von Laufwegen erzählen. Und Dieter Schatzschneider wollte nichts davon hören. Also Dieter Schatzschneider auch ein Mann. Oper erzählen wir vom Krieg ein kleines bisschen. Man kann es trotzdem lesen. So, dann hat Saskia Aleite, die wunderbare Saskia Aleite, die auch in diesem aktuellen Magazin etwas beisteuert, hat hier zum Beispiel mit Dorothea Vira gesprochen. Ganz spannend fand ich das, weil damals, 2020, war die Biathlon-WM in Andholz eine der letzten Veranstaltungen, die vor diesem ganzen Corona-Mist wirklich mit Zuschauern ausgetragen wurden. Und Dorothea Vira ist dort Weltmeisterin geworden. Und Doro, wie wir, engere Bekannte und Fans, sagen dürfen, hat damals schon gesagt, ich weiß nicht, ob ich mich überhaupt noch weiter motivieren kann. Sagt es auch in diesem Interview. Keine Ahnung, ob ich nächstes Jahr noch dabei bin. Und wenn man jetzt schaut, vergangenes Wochenende in Oestersund, ich habe leider an der Big Show niemand gefunden. Saskia wehrt sich noch, aber ich werde sie noch rumkriegen für kommende Woche. Hoffentlich. In Oestersund ist die Biathlon-Saison losgegangen, Dorothea Viera immer noch dabei. Also wunderschön. Und es sind lauter Interviews und das habe ich aus meiner Erfahrung als Spiegelleser auch. Das erste, was ich immer gelesen habe im Spiegel waren die Interviews, weil es sich dann am Ende des Tages leichter liest. Ihr seht ja auch einen Motorsportler. Ja, das ist der Sportskamerad Ericsson, der auch alle Klassen durchlaufen hat. Wunderbar, Franz Büchner, der immer dabei ist. Interview gleich mit zwei Eishockeyspielern, also wer sich für die DL interessiert. Heiko Ohlderb, auch ein Interview. Ja, was soll ich sagen? Es ist wunderbar geworden. Ich habe noch ein paar Exemplare, bestellt das gerne dazu. Noch wichtiger natürlich das aktuelle Heft.
Hat das denselben Preis? Also einfach alles mal zwei. Nehmt es einfach mal zwei, liebe Leute, 13,60 Euro mal zwei, beziehungsweise 15,30 Euro. Dann fällt nämlich auch ein bisschen was für dich ab, weil, das muss man ja dazu sagen, du machst das viel länger als der Rasenfunk, aber auch viel viel weniger als der Rasenfunk. Naja, so ehrlich muss man es ja sagen. Es ist bei dir ein Hobbyprojekt, was du immer noch neben deinem Beruf quetschst, was ich irre finde, weil ich könnte das nicht mehr.
Du bist ja ein doppelter Genius. Das eine ist, wie du den Rasenfunk machst, das andere ist aber auch, wie früh du erkannt hast, was man noch zusätzlich machen muss. Und ich weiß, du hast mich auch vor Jahren immer gepusht und gesagt, Jens, das ist Arbeit. Es ist halt Arbeit auch, die Verbreitung des Ganzen. Und da habe ich massiv geschlammt. Was heißt massiv geschlammt? Aber ich hatte mal einen Stamm und dann, ist natürlich auch saublöd, dann ist meine ganze Seite zusammengebrochen. Und meine ganzen Feeds haben nicht mehr funktioniert, musste mir wieder neu laden. Da habe ich dann doch etliche Hörer verloren. Aber ja, ich bin ein Bruchteil von deinen Hörern. Ich glaube, es gibt eine Schnittmenge auch bei uns.
Also weiß ich auch.
Aber natürlich der Rasenfunk ist viel, viel größer. Und deshalb freut es mich umso mehr, dass ich heute hier meine Bescheidung, das kleines Projekt vorstellen darf, das übrigens 2005 schon den ersten Versuch gestartet hat.
Ja, klar. Neben dem Leierkasten. Die Geschichte dieser fast schon ein alter Leierkasten.
Es ist fast ein alter Leier, aber da hat sich eben schon herauskristallisiert, was ich machen wollte. Damals hatte ich Wolf Fuss, Michael Leopold, Markus Gaub, Michael Körner und Markus Gravenkel. Und irgendwie ist es, das ist bei mir halt nach wie vor so, dass ich versuche Leute in meine Show zu bekommen, die wirklich beruflich mit dieser ganzen Geschichte zu tun haben. Wenn ich eben, also ich hatte vor zwei Wochen, hat mir sehr gut gefallen, du wirst schon auch gehört haben, Mark Heinrich von der FAZ. Und Jan Platte von der ZONE. Also Jan finde ich, höre ich sehr, sehr gerne zu. Und Jan gerade auch mit Sandro Wagner habe ich auch sehr gerne zugehört, weil dort die Chemie, im Gegensatz zu Sandro Wagner mit Bellareti, da hat die Chemie nicht gepasst, fand ich. But anyway, die Leute sind nahe dran. Und wir kommen dann auf die Eintracht zu sprechen. Und Mark Heinrich ist ja für die FAZ, war da in Finnland mit dabei. Und Jan hatte das Spiel von der Eintracht bei der ZONE, hat sich super vorbereitet drauf. Und da sitze ich dann nur da und höre gern zu, wie die Leute, die sich wirklich damit auskennen und die im Thema drinnen sind. Ich versuche dann ein Stichwort zu geben, gelingt mir nicht immer. Aber sowas freut mich dann. Da bin ich dann da und denke mir, okay, deswegen mache ich das.
Ja, und man hat auch das Gefühl, es ist für beide Seiten gut, denn die Kommentatorinnen und Kommentatoren haben ja das Problem, die lesen sich quasi immer die Encyclopedia Britannica an für ein Spiel und werden dann ein Bruchteil davon los. Und bei dir kommt es dann manchmal noch mal so aus dem Stammhörn nach oben geschwemmt und dann können sie richtig abnerden über Sachen, die ihnen aufgefallen sind. Und das finde ich eben auch. Und es gibt so ganze Sportarten, da informiere ich mich nur über die Big Show. Also zum Beispiel die Rugby-WM. Ich wusste, dass ich sie hätte sehen sollen.
Ich habe auch zu wenig gesehen, aber ich habe immer meine Sendung gehört.
Ich habe das Finale und eins der Halbfinals habe ich gesehen, in einem Irish Pub damals auch. Es musste Viertelfinale gewesen sein, wo sie gegen die Neuseeland ausgeschieden sind. Ich wusste, ich hätte es sehen müssen, weil es eben ein fantastischer Sport, ein fantastisches Turnier gewesen. Aber es geht halt einfach nicht, wenn du das ganze Wochenende arbeitest. Inzwischen gucke ich unter der Woche manchmal noch Sachen nach, die ich verpasst habe, also aus dem Fußballbereich. Ich schaffe es einfach nicht. Und dann weiß ich aber, da kommen Jan Lüdecke und zweiten Namen leider gerade. Genau, danke schön.
Und Nikola, der das moderiert, ist auch total tief im Thema.
Ja, und ist aber immer ab einem Punkt deprimiert, weil Frankreich ausgeschieden ist. Also so war es bisher bei allen rugby-Segmenten, die ich gehört habe in der Big Show. Aber da weiß ich eben, und die kommen dann auch mit einer Begeisterung, die für mich sogar manchmal so ein bisschen drüber ist, dass ich mir denke, ja, hey, Jungs, jetzt kommt mal runter. Das ist doch gar kein Fußball. Wie kann man sich dafür so begeistern? Aber das ist einfach schön. Und diese Begeisterung trägst du ja auch in dir für gewisse Sportarten quasi intrinsisch, für andere verlängert über die Gäste. Und deswegen finde ich es sehr gut, dass der Sportradio360 noch gibt, trotz aller Probleme und so weiter und so fort. Und ich hoffe, dass es auch noch lange weiter so geht. Und da könnt ihr jetzt unter anderem einen Beitrag leisten, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, indem man so etwas unterstützt und sich so ein Heft kauft und damit ja auch dich unterstützt. Und ich vermute, du hast es mir im Vorgespräch nicht gesagt, aber ich vermute, dass viel zu wenig von den 13,60 Euro bei dir hängen bleiben wird.
Ja, wie gesagt, also die Bilder sind wirklich teuer. Und ich habe den Druck, also das hat der Dre, du kennst ja auch Andre Vogt, der ist auch bei mir öfter zu Gast, der hat ja auch dieses Got Next-Magazin. Also seit 2020 sind auch die Papierpreise enorm gestiegen.
Das ist krass, das ist wirklich krass.
Das sind Kleinigkeiten, an die man vielleicht nicht so denkt. Und ja, also ich freue mich über jeden, der bei mir reinhört. Wenn jetzt jemand dazukommt, gerne. Also diese Begeisterung, wie Max sagt, ich teile sie nicht für alle Sportarten. Ich kehre mich vom Fußball. Ich habe viele Verbesserungsvorschläge. Vielleicht liebe ich den Fußball doch noch, weil ich Verbesserungsvorschläge hätte. Aber es gibt halt manche Sportarten, wie Tennis, wo ich hauptberuflich mit Tennis beschäftigt bin. Und Skifahren. Also jetzt im Winter, da gehe ich natürlich auf. Und auch wenn ich Petra Vlohe mit Petra Quitto war, das ist einfach nur meinem jugendlichen Enthusiasmus geschuldet.
Ja, und man kann ganze Sportarten wirklich sehr gut über das Sportradio360 verfolgen. Ich habe keine einzige Minute Formel 1 gesehen in den letzten zwei, vielleicht sogar drei Jahren. Weiß aber alles. Ferrari macht Fehler. Toto Wolf hat auf ein falsches Auto gesetzt. Max Verstappen wird aber auch nächstes Jahr wieder Weltmeister. Also ich weiß jetzt schon alles. Ja genau, wozu die ganzen Bums noch gucken. Du ersetzt diese Sportarten peu à peu. Jens, vielen, vielen Dank, dass du da warst. Ich bin mir sicher, ich werde in den Show Notes alle Informationen nochmal hinterlegen. Und diejenigen, die das jetzt gesehen haben, das was Jens gezeigt hat, war ein selbst produzierter Dummy.
Das Magazin sieht deutlich besser aus.
Denn das wird jetzt gerade mit seinen fast 300 Kilo Dier zugestellt. Deswegen musst du schnell nach Hause, um das entgegenzunehmen, würde ich sagen, damit es nicht im Schnee Münchens liegt.
Max, ich danke wieder, dass ich zu Gast sein durfte. Es ist so eine große Freude.
Es war wirklich eine große Freude, dich mal wieder hier zu haben. Danke dir, lieber Jens, und danke euch, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, für eure Aufmerksamkeit und allen Zusehenden auf YouTube. Ihr wisst, was zu tun ist. Und wenn ihr damit fertig seid, dann könnt ihr auch auf rasenfunk.de noch mal gucken, was wir sonst so veröffentlicht haben. Gestern ist eine Ligatur erschienen zum europäischen Männerfußball und auch zum Männerbundesliga-Spieltag. Wird es wieder was geben. Schwerpunkt der nächsten Woche werden Freiburg und Gladbach. Und dann gibt es auch noch was zur zweiten Liga. Also es geht hier als durch. Macht's gut, bleibt gesund, bis bald.
Der Rasenfunk lebt von euren Beiträgen. Vielen Dank!